salut à tous c'est ludo de la chaîne
youtube de tête aujourd'hui je suis avec
brut et on va parler d'une pratique
divise les campagnes françaises
d'un côté il ya ceux qui soutiennent une
tradition ancestrale de l'autre des
défenseurs de l'environnement qui se
battent pour l'abolir la chasse à courre
propre ça n'existe pas il ya tout le
temps la violence sous le temps de
recruter c'est la finalité de la chasse
à courre ne peut pas dire que ce soit
une nouvelle classe c'est pas vrai et au
milieu de ça il ya des riverains qui
veulent juste être tranquille mais si on
a des enfants on a des mamans on a des
familles et on a peur c'est vrai qu'on a
peur elle déchaîne les passions et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
avec brut je vais vous parler de la
chasse à courre aujourd'hui les parties
de chasse à courre finit souvent en
confrontation entre les militants pro et
anti chasse il se filme mutuellement se
provoque
et parfois même ils en viennent aux
mains tu t'es pas du tout du trésor
[Musique]
mais avant de vous raconter tout ça
faudrait peut-être que je vous explique
c'est quoi la chasse à courre la chasse
à courre d'ailleurs c'est plutôt la
chasse à courre à cor et à cri ou la
vénerie consiste à chasser un animal
sauvage uniquement avec une meute de
chiens ce sont les chiens qui
poursuivent le gibier encadré par un
équipage qui est à cheval ou même à pied
qu'on appelle les veneurs après
plusieurs heures de poursuite le gibier
épuisé et services est à dire tué par
l'un des veneurs avec une lance l'animal
tué n'ai pas mangé par les chasseurs
mais il est servi aux chiens lors d'une
cérémonie que les veneurs rappelle la
curée en vénerie on peut chasser la
moitié de l'année des espèces bien
spécifique le cerf le chevreuil le
sanglier le renard le lièvre et le lapin
mais bon le plus simple c'est quand on
regarde comment ça se passe là on
cherche la trace d'un cerf ce qu'on
appelle plus communément le vosseler le
gosselet donc c'est l'empreinte de
l'animal que le sait que le ser laisse
sur le terrain
[Musique]
c'est un temps qu'il s'est mis à tirer
fort et en fait il y avait le petit
animal ici là il montre donc le rôle
essentiel de ce matin c'est de pouvoir
remettre un animal à un endroit bien
définis au pouvoir l'attaquer avec ses
congénères tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on va partir à cheval de la
champignonnière avec les chiens et donc
on va descendre et on va passer par le
village comme d'habitude descendra jusqu
en forêt on ira à la briser à cheval
avec les chiens
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
lors de cette chasse aucune bête n'a été
prise et d'après les veneurs il n'arrive
réellement apprendre le gibier qu'une
fois sur quatre pour la curée c'est un
peu plus compliqué de vous montrer des
images parce qu'en général les caméras
ne sont pas les bienvenues lors de cette
cérémonie
aulas vous fatiguez pas
[Musique]
montrez-nous une purée alors je vous
avais alors dauphin savoir rien à cacher
il ya patricia c'est pas hyper qu
évidemment pas dans un abattoir
d'ailleurs évidemment elle a jamais été
ballot visant la mise à mort c'est un
acte moche qualifiée de cruelle et
barbare par ses détracteurs la chasse à
courre est défendu par ses sympathisants
moi je comprends tout à fait qu'ils
aient des gens qui considèrent que de
chasser un animal pendant des heures
soit cruel mais en fait ce sont des gens
qui connaissent pas parce que ce qu'on
fait faire à l'animal ça n'est pas d'une
cruauté extraordinaire
l'animal est dans son élément deuxième
point le discours devant les chiens et
cette course
finalement elle est une course qui fait
quoi disons 2 2 entre 2 et 4 heures et
qui est pas très différente de ce que
fait un marathonien quand il fait 40 km
au cours des 6 et je suis très tournée
vers les animaux donc j'aime beaucoup
mon cheval et puis
les chiens travail des chiens c'est
extraordinaire avoir bien sûr de pour la
chasse c'est un peu la bellerie c'est un
pur tout est parti de là
de la france acer hippiques ibérique une
bêche à ce qu'ils puissent se défendre
et parce que je sais pas mais pas repris
à chaque fois lors de la les tracteurs
parfois ils souffrent
l'animal tout le monde souffre les
images chocs rossi si les boules en
train de bourrer vous parlez je souffre
de la ville mais voilà il y en a qui ne
sont pas vraiment d'accord avec ça et
c'est ce qu'on va voir avec jimmy qui
avec d'autres militants anti chasse
s'organise pour empêcher cette pratique
donc la cdc des veneurs ou des gens qui
sont proches des joueurs qui vont nous
suivre en forêt officiellement c'est
pour empêcher qu'on fasse des bêtises en
tout cas c'est leur version mais sont
surtout là pour nous empêcher de filmer
et éventuellement nous agresser si si on
passe devant la chasse marée en poussant
à des images compromettantes
c'est eux qui viennent en forêt où nous
poursuivre la chasse n'avancions pas les
rôles ensuite mot sur les lacets pour
empêcher qu'ils veulent les chiens comme
il le profond qu'ils agressent les
veneurs un ami quand une minerve quinze
jours après son agression par jimmy
s'est pas
c'est bon alors c'est bon ils sont
partis chasser là bas ok en gros il sont
partis ont peu de spectacle
[Musique]
un cadeau qui est passée par là
peut-être qu'on se rapproche peut pas
s'en suit les consignes qu'on m'a donnée
aujourd'hui c'est de vous dire que
j'étais une propriété privée est
interdit dans et pour nouveau à d'un
rôle de prévention de police - police de
la chasse aux listes l'accord dont vous
êtes à son avantage oui tout à fait je
te voir avec l'avion
[Musique]
ethan matricule ona
commencer un agrément c'est pas une
assermentation le passé montré que
monsieur te notifie que c'est une
propriété privée il a menti aussi tutoie
la non mais là c'est pas marqué est
propre et la moyenne des prix vraiment
que voilà votre rôle de prévention
on vous remercie bonne journée la non là
il faudra que dans le côté spectaculaire
parce que les journalistes mais sinon
c'est beaucoup plus agressif j'ai fait
d'avoir une pression récurrente sur les
équipages ça les oblige à faire plus
attention à leurs pratiques
ça aussi ça passe l'envié à certains
d'aller chasser
c'est une pratique qui coûte très cher
donc les gens plus forcément vite autant
investir d'autant aller chasser sachant
qu'ils passeront une mauvaise journée du
faible présence est toujours eu des gens
qui n'est pas la chasse ça on l'entend
bien même pas l'achat géré la chose
mais aujourd'hui dans les gens qui
disent moi j'aime pas la chasse mais je
veux pas que tu chasses moi j'aime pas
la viande et je veux pas que tu en
manges
moi j'aime bien les blés les petits
veaux et je veux pas qu'on en élèves
pour les tuer moi j'aime bien les
taureaux je veux pas qu'on fasse de la
corrida c'est le cetc d'une forme
d'intolérance
est-ce que ça m'inquiète oui oui parce
que ses clients voilà on est en train de
fracturer fortement la société moi je
suis dans mon droit
vous vous l'êtes pas vous venez nous
emmerder tu as une preuve de ce que tu
dis est ce que je suis impliqué dans une
seule dans une seule écoute je peux dire
qu'il va pas de 18 vous l'aurez compris
c'est hyper tendu entre pro et
anti-chasse et d'ailleurs quand les
caméras des journalistes ne sont pas là
c'est un peu plus violent que ce qu'on a
pu voir
au-delà de ces deux camps qui s'opposent
il y à des riverains qui aimerait juste
que leur propriété privée soit respectée
c'est le cas de xavier un professionnel
du tourisme qui louent des logements au
coeur de la nature nous ici au quotidien
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on est envahi
par la chasse à courre
on a des clients qui viennent là et des
chiens qui déambulent absolument partout
mais qui déambulent pourquoi pour
repérer le gibier justement à traquer en
l'occurrence le cerf ou le sanglier
on peut faire le planning des chasses en
a marre des chasses attire le mercredi
chasse à courre le jeudi chasse à courre
au chevreuil le vendredi chasse à courre
au sanglier le samedi on à la chasse à
courre auxerre le dimanche on à la
chasse dominicale un climat assez
particulier quand même ici on regardait
plus près ce que dit la loi
elle explique que nul n'a la faculté de
chasser sur la propriété d'autrui sans
le consentement du propriétaire ou de
ses ayants droit mais la loi autorise à
achever un animal mortellement blessé
car ce n'est pas considérée comme un
acte de chasse mais depuis peu un arrêté
a mis fin à cette autorisation si
l'animal se trouve près d'habitations de
jardins privés de zones commerciales
en gros on n'a plus le droit de tuer un
animal chez quelqu'un mais apparemment
c'est compliqué de tout maîtriser
j'ai le trac et barrez vous barrez vous
mais c'est affreux voir et vous rappeler
vos chiens
on m'avait donc là quatre ou cinq chiens
je sais pas qui était sur la bête
la bête qui hurlait je vous laisse
imaginer la bande son du truc quoi est
clairement ils l'ont dépassé vivant
après il a réussi à repartir à aller un
petit peu plus sur la gauche là je tiens
qu'est venu que consomme choper la
langue et après ils ont fait la dorsale
ils ont mangé toute la dorsale des fous
je veux pas être votre ami quand on fait
des courriers recommandés
1 2 3 4 quand on contacte les équipages
quand on contacte la police la
gendarmerie la police de la chasse et
rien qui change nous la volonté est là
clairement on veut pas arrêter la chasse
on n'arrêtera jamais la chasse on
demande juste simplement à respirer
tranquillement est en sécurité chez nous
à pouvoir exercer notre activité
sereinement
c'est un comble tout simplement en
angleterre et au pays de galles la
chasse à courre a été interdite avec le
holding actes au début des années 2000
mais elle est encore légal en france est
défendue par certains pour d'autres il
est temps que cette pratique cesse alors
tradition noble ou pratiques barbares
à vous de vous faire votre propre avis
quand j'ai déjà le mien
[Musique]